this logos weird man like of all the
big-budget effects driven movies Jerry
Bruckheimer's produced
twister ain't womp hot and ranchers have
a proud history me if there was one
movie that had no need for opening their
exposition it's this movie so seen this
twice then remember Rangers lead the way
well not really anymore I mean they won
the AL West in 2016 but since then
they've been totally in rebuilding mode
you gonna be miss Alabama that make sure
that is very bra and sexist he's a
regular reg regular hound now I'm not
sitting the character for making this
terrible pun because he's clearly drunk
but I am sending the screenwriter for
the first of many
terrible puns in the script why don't
you go buy me my buddies round
did he just throw money at him so the
insult is that he gives him the money
for the drinks but wants him to be the
middleman when you're talking is
basically just asking someone to run an
errand for you you may need some asshole
wing lessons what is it Tricia on shift
right now shouldn't she be servicing
this very busy oyster bar and if it's no
big deal if she take some time off why
didn't she meet Poe at the airport and
erased the very stupid inciting incident
for this movie so these assholes waited
for Tricia to finish working then waited
in this pouring rain just a with Cameron
like that's not even drunk behavior
that's obsession with a dude they just
met tonight Wow in this fight against a
highly decorated Army Ranger this
assholes first impulse is to rip off
Cameron's fucking badges
Simon West does not ground MAMP
Cameron's been back home for a cup of
coffee and a Trisha Yearwood song and
has already killed a guy
and I can immediately diagnose this
within seconds despite being the
bartender at the least fancy Oyster Bar
in Mobile Alabama you think in 10 years
to get polar the most ludicrous thing
about this ludicrous movie is the idea
of a white guy getting this long of a
sentence in Alabama you are a deadly
weapon and are not subject to the same
laws as other people that have provoked
wait what his uniform was torn his wife
witnessed three men attack him and he
was injured not to mention character
witnesses witnesses the provocation at
the bar broken bottle pieces spoofy
should have just been over in six
minutes
and I'm blaming this idiot lawyer and
judge for whatever the next two hours
holds the character walks into prison
for the first time and gets aggressively
and immediately catcalled in a movie
cliche seriously can't there be one
movie when the population welcomes a new
member with like a carrot cake or
something I'm not angry
the blooms got a fall on me after all I
shouldn't let them Boas stab me for
having the gall to dance with my wife
they were perfectly within their rights
I am however torn apart when I think
that I won't be there to see our child
coming to the world look I personally
want this entire video to be an
indictment on Nicolas Cage's attempted
to southern accents it's maybe the worst
accent attempt since Keanu Reeves tried
to be British in Dracula but since we
have to move on to other things here's
300 sins and honestly I think the movies
getting a bargain I got your package
those paint coconut things have made me
quite popular and thank you for packing
them so neatly so that the audience
could read the brand names clearly hey
Roger what's a prison riot look like I'm
guessing a bunch of bunks and some fires
that enough yeah they probably also TP
the whole area for effect Roger you are
genius seriously NIC cages workout
routine montage lasts longer in this
movie than the goddamn trial school is
very important the mom is right I swear
Nic Cage is a box of chocolates away
from doing a complete Forrest Gump
impersonation you might as well just
make his cellmate Bubba and call it good
holy whoa it's that horror movie artwork
did Casey paint that if so Cameron's
incarceration had a tough impact on that
poor girl this is like something the kid
from the ring would paint I think it not
juicy all right get on foreplay as you
know today's flight is no greater sign
of oncoming exposition and the character
telling a bunch of people something they
already know it's my daughter's birthday
congratulations I got locked down three
months before she was born
hey and I'm oversharing this much
because we only have
a few minutes to bond so that you can
later immediately trust me on this
dangerous flight oh look he wears socks
with sandals
he must be quirky and brilliant parking
in the handicapped slot the go-to for
anytime you need a character to look
like an asshole and subtlety isn't a
concern we pick up mr. Savino in Carson
City from veteran till the plane hits
Alabama we've got two hours to get him
to talk what let's assume that this
prison is somewhere in central Alabama
it takes at least five hours to get from
Carson City to anywhere near that
location I don't care if Google wasn't
around in 1997 this is a pretty silly
miscalculation that's William Bedford
aka Billy bedlam mass murder the intros
for the convicts are so stupid and
stylized that they might as well be
accompanied by Suicide Squad style
graphics he wrote a book in prison New
York Times called it a wake-up call for
the black community they're talking to
Denzel for the movie I know I should be
surprised by how dismissively racist
this movie is in retrospect but I'm not
really surprised by Hub dismissively
racist this movie is in retrospect tell
me skip it's the US Marshal Service in
the habit of employing annoying wiseass
bookworm creeps we even do back in 1997
that anti-intellectualism was an asshole
trait glad we took care of that then so
it can't bother us today sure clean up
at the Fifty Shades convention they said
it'll be an easy 25 dollars they said
certainly SEPA honestly the only more
random Dave Chappelle appearance in a
movie is a star's born what's the
in-flight movie today well I think
you'll like it Cyrus it's called I'll
never make love to a woman on the beach
again wait I guess that kind of means
I'm a prisoner too this goes smoothly
all those monsters hide oh right sounds
like a great idea you know I've been
thinking about this plan a lot it
requires pinball to start the fire in
the back cabin then Bishop has to be the
one to open the gate and get the
extinguisher and she has to have her
keys easily accessible then she'd leave
plenty of time for pinball to release
diamond dog and he himself is able to
take out the many guards in the front
cabin my point is that maybe it's not
impossible but this motherfucker is way
too easy to random bullets and both hit
unimportant characters in fatal areas
and neither hits anything vital on the
plane also a victim of the shooting
logic and as you say worried about this
over the radio the next wings you see
will belong to the flies buzzing over
your rotting corpse man I bet this line
looked great on paper and it sounds
great coming out of John Malkovich but I
the only gun on board welcome to Conair
roll inmates this is your captain so
that's it but guards look like they've
actually got the upper hand here and the
only advantage Cyrus has is the gun sure
it's a big advantage but they still have
numbers and they have to know about the
Arsenal in the belly of the plane
there's a little ruckus in the pilot
hippie laughs wait so that pilot went
along with it even after killing ray
cyrus stepped out of the cockpit I swear
this whole plan is just a giant bowl of
this works too also you know it was
Ginny that raised concerns about this
flight in the first place but now that
there's an actual alert she's super call
I know the pilot said everything is fine
but she's not even suspicious machete
diamond dog if you would thank you free
did they rehearse this my just diamond
dog have to do the motivational speech
about the next steps
Cyrus is literally right there I know
we're all nervous that the gun is going
to be found but the real question is how
is it not seen by the person who locked
his ankles down in the first place Jesus
Christ
seems might not be the sharpest tool in
the shed but how on earth does he expect
this to work this line is so good
relative to the rest of the script that
I choose to believe it was Dave
Chappelle improvising Bob because I'm
not sure and I'm too lazy to look it up
I'm giving it a sit
nice work huh truly nice work what did
Poe really do sure he kind of distracted
the DEA guy but seems like Cyrus would
have higher standards for this type of
praise the guys they're expecting our
white that puts you down these assholes
are gonna be transferred to another
prison though right so it's conceptually
much luckier to be on this flight
considering Cyrus doesn't know about
baby o's diabetes Carson study says we
got a hell of a sandstorm down there it
is perfect since they can now disguise
themselves even further it's almost like
God wants these motherfuckers to escape
and they're somehow gonna screw it up
well my second ago you couldn't wait to
get off this plane no no your friend I
guess this works now what will my
daughter think of me if I let you like
this to get dishonored I look I'm gonna
be honest I expected a ton of sins for
this movie to this point but there's
just so much like this line it's
definitely sinful but really just since
itself listen again now what will my
daughter think of me if I lift you like
this to get this on and die you see
oh yeah Cyrus had plenty of time to Andy
Dufresne his prison cell with plaster
even though he's under constant
surveillance I don't care if he's got a
goddamn hood on
Cyrus is apparently one of the most
recognized criminals in the system but
this correctional officer doesn't
recognize his ass even this clothes also
what was the plan if there wasn't a
sandstorm he'd still walk out with the
masking goggles and no one would notice
starting to think these assholes are
actively in on this plan you gotta be
kidding me how long is it gonna take for
Lloyd Dobler to put together man he's
been looking at these pictures for
several minutes but hasn't radioed to
the plane this is like Butthead looking
at the window the footprints and the
missing TV over and over again yes we're
not only adding a previously unknown
entity to this highly regulated prison
transfer he's gonna be the most murdery
of all those motherfuckers good luck
yeah but steve buscemi still look
creepier as crazy eyes and that Adam
Sandler movie that's gonna go man
Butch's 37 people up and down the
eastern seaboard
whispers position also even if these are
convicts what makes them goddamn experts
on the other evil or convicts how even
later knows the exact details of Cindy
knows lesser known crimes like is the
literature on the criminals available in
the prison library and if so why it's
physically spiritually psychically
emotionally and physically impossible
for this movie to get any dumber got a
situation here sir somebody better call
the marshal's office this is the radio
equivalent of you better come take a
look at this cliche where is a
transponder where indeed not content to
just show us tom friendly hot-wiring the
transponder and having it taken out of
the plane movie wants to make sure we
get it by taking another few minutes to
spell it out in conversation so did
Larkin intentionally wrinkle his suit
did it come nice and press from the
store but he crumpled it up and threw it
into a corner of his closet before you
could wear it he just took that barely
used cigarette out of his mouth and
chucked it on the floor it's a bad for
the health bad for the environment bad
for the wallet trifecta situation has
ever been contemplate well do you better
start contemplating no one ever
contemplated the inmates taking over the
plane on the list of things to
contemplate when putting inmates on the
plane shouldn't that at least be toward
the top Cyrus Grissom you copy
so they discovered the schematics and
Cyrus's cell they deciphered the code
they've been through the bomb blast in
the cell run through the entire tape
from the DEA agent and they're just now
contacting the planes radio Oh
nothing makes me sadder than the agent
lost his bladder in the okay I've gone
as far as I can without taking a sin off
of this Malkovich performance this is
prime Malkovich people except they
somehow managed to get every creep and
freak in the universe onto this one
plane and then somehow managed to let
them take it over and then somehow
managed to stick us right smack in the
middle I know we're pronoun gaming here
but is the they in this situation the
screenwriter by the way what did baby O
do that landed him in prison not like
he's getting out anytime soon since he
was getting transferred presumably to
that supermax prison in Alabama but he's
good because he's diabetic got in a
drunken brawl defending his wife and he
killed a guy could happen to any one of
us damn if only camera that had the
legal mind of US Marshal Vince Larkin on
his defense team despite John Cusack
yelling this about the director he was
allowed to continue making this film we
dragged him baby the landing gear all
the way up and I just figured no one
would ask me about it so I haven't said
anything for this entire flight yeah but
this is our pinball fell over Oh running
neck to neck with a plane that's lifting
off my do so how in the ever-loving did
he end up here also the production
budget must have been sapped after
casting all this star power because
clearly nothing was spent on this
Chappelle dummy seriously look at that
like a toddler me to clay sculpture in
art class and then quit halfway through
there's no way this is cruising altitude
and a plane of this type at this height
would draw all kinds of suspicion movie
doesn't even know how to airplane not
only does this body not explode on
impact it's somehow picks a busy
intersection instead of the top of a
building or an unpopulated area you say
you had 15 years but in now we'll put
you on North Block funny thing I was on
North Block I don't know you gives it
about criminals and movies that makes
them expert detectives why the hell
would Billy care where Poe was in the
prison especially when they're you know
in the middle of a daring aerial escape
from prison
what's wrong with I'm more concerned
with why baby it was sweating so much I
think it's supposed to be a reminder
that he needs insulin but high blood
sugar doesn't cause sweating thirst
exhaustion and frequent urination shirt
but sweating like you're starring in a
time to kill isn't usually on the
symptoms list hey those are my shades
you're mine now system
man man this movie is trying to be
offensive to everyone and it's
succeeding dude you have this whole
giant road and you're driving right down
the middle Wow could you put the bunny
back in the box
wait I think I've heard this one because
it was having a bad hair day did I get
it right
that aircrafts carrying 30 prisoners hey
if this pilot would make that outdated
of a reference on Mary Pickford one girl
I drove through three states wearing her
head as a hat sure this is supposed to
show crazy old Garland's true colors but
how would that work did he have to
balance it on top of his head the whole
time or did you take her face off oh
look that's potentially blood let me dip
my fingers in it to make sure better yet
let me dip my balls in that stuff also
what happened to Larkins cell phone he
sees the dead body and the destroyed
radio but he sees no need to call this
in the last guy who told me to have
patience I burned them down and bagged
his ashes damn even for Cyrus this seems
like a massive overreaction my own
proclivities are well known and often
lamented facts of penal lore gosh this
is your barbecue man and it tastes good
this line is so bad that it's even worse
than the rest of the script and I'm
choosing to believe that it was Nicolas
Cage improvising because I'm not sure
and I'm too lazy to look it up I'm
giving it us in how long we got till
they get here now ten twelve minutes
tops twelve minutes let's say
conservatively they're speeding at you
at about 75 miles an hour it's going to
take them 12 minutes they would be carry
the three exponent of the mean Oh done
further away than you can see when the
earth curves out of sight just over
three miles away you got a friend on
board see I knew I was right about you I
read your file
movie it's time for this hell Larkin has
time for this also those South American
thugs that ambushed Poe are still
hanging around right I mean one of them
was shot in the leg but he's not
unconscious or anything oh just kicked
his gun over to the side a little bit
we're gonna try and pull it out of the
sand
if Jett likely weighs over 700,000
pounds and with 14 men and a
tractor-trailer pulling that means each
person would have to pull back to the
five multiple PI a done more than
humanly possible until the wheels are on
flat ground look I'm not advocating for
child murder or anything but Looby takes
great pains to set up this whole creepy
Garland little girl thing and he
ultimately leaves her alone why child
murders like his whole thing right sigh
Inara guy Barbie wants to sin how
painfully stupid this line is
part of me loves the camp dammit it's
just too stupid this movie gave reality
the finger about an hour ago
assassinated it a few minutes later and
it's now gleefully enjoying dry humping
its corpse if they're not expecting an
ambush why did they get out here they
are expecting an ambush why did they
drive through here random cut to Danny
Trejo is truly random he seriously left
the fight so he could go try and assault
dish this is an absurd commitment to
this characters pathology movie Wow look
at this guy really struggling to be dead
like he knows he's in the shot but he's
trying hardest to be dead Gunn's stuff
flying breaking no easing truckin
excitement what was the plan here did
they even fill up or put any fuel in
this plane whatsoever these
motherfuckers start drinking and
celebrating as soon as they take off so
they somehow think they're free but they
have to know there are a ton of
helicopters right behind them right how
did the Rope get under the front of the
car wouldn't have had to pass through
the tyres to travel underneath it like
this no it was right there the only
person in movie history to even suggest
going for the tires it's at this point
that everyone on the plane is listening
to Sweet Home Alabama I can't wait until
one of them busts a dope freestyle to
Mekhi Phifer about living in a trailer
pretty clever huh bitch
no that's clever Twitter I'm not
supposed to make it yeah man I get that
feeling too
since you've literally spent this entire
movie dining of different things I'm
gonna show you God doesn't exist
oh come on PO this is not the time for
sexy talk there have been so many
bullets unloaded in this flying metal
tube without incident that luck and
coincidence must be sixty-nining
somewhere nearby cool it's finally
sunset this has been the longest date
ever by the way it was in the same day
they've had time to transport Po and
baby Oh from San Quentin to the airfield
load up all the first batch of criminals
at them stage of coup fly all the way to
Carson City make another prison transfer
get into a gunfight fly back to Lerner
airfield dig out the plane get into a
huge gun fight then fly to Vegas and
there's a bunch of other stuff like post
family flying all over the country
that's similarly unbelievable but just
trust me that this whole timeline is
bold or clear strips where I'm gonna
land but McCarran Airport is literally
right next to the strip goddamn for a
kinetic movie it's lazy I'm just gonna
approximate but I think this is a full
fifty five minutes of landing and
crashing mmm Jesus Christ look at all
that crash you
ouch damn this is absurd but I gotta
admit it's mesmerizing so let me get the
street you want the propeller to not
only dislodge but boomerang back to the
plane yes and have it passed right
between them before he shoots PO
wouldn't it kill them no they'll totally
jump out of the way but no human can
react that quick and the propeller would
just be breaking the laws of physics if
the propeller slicing clean through a
plane no one will care
cinemasins cares motherfucker cinemasins
cares man Larkins carrying that gun with
the reckless abandon you'd see from the
policeman and plan 9 from outer space
Oh next time take the bus movie cruelly
teases a speed Conair hybrid that I'm
definitely not emotionally prepared for
holy the Marshalls flew Poe's family out
to this incredibly unsafe environment to
surprise him the fucking fuck a plane
crashed in the middle of the city like
only minutes ago I just realized that
the only previous times I'd seen this
movie I'd been drinking that I totally
enjoyed this movie during those times
but I'm not enjoying it now while
soberly dissecting it hang on let me do
a few shots
[Music]
you killed that guy with a big
motorcycle haha I don't wanna close my
miss your baby I've got a long missile
thing Oh what's in the box what's in the
box
I will not play guilty you could get 10
years and years man 10 10 years 10 years
10 10
[Music]
how
you've been in the celebrity room before
with other clients depends on the artist
you know there's a fleecy Anna you got
no complaints
he's going very fast
hey that's William Bedford aka Billy
bedlam you gotta kick it off with a
killer to grab attention but you're
looking at Punk what are you looking at
Butthead what do you want well I know
what the plan is I'll be damned if I
didn't get really turned on what you're
engaged in is blackmail that is a felony
Oh captain another captain now